tic le premier alors trois amendements
identiques de suppression l'amendement
numéro un monsieur kerrouche
merci madame la présidente cet
amendement constitue forcément le
dispositif central de l'as de la loi
puisqu'il est le seul à il est le seul à
demeurer
l'opposition nous l'avons vu dans les
discussions que nous venons d'avoir il
ya une opposition forte de philosophie
d'un côté ceux qui ont déposé cette loi
et qui considèrent que leur tour un
cumul même tempéré du cumul des mandats
serait une nécessité et un retour entre
guillemets à la normale et nous qui
considérons que ce n'est pas un retour à
la normale mais plutôt un retour à une
pathologie qu'il vaut mieux éviter
les arguments qui sont ceux qui ont été
développés de la déconnexion ne nous
semble absolument pas pertinent dans
l'ensemble des démocraties occidentales
qu'il s'agisse de
d'état unitaire ou d'états fédéraux pour
que les choses soient claires le cumul
ou est une acception où n'existe pas et
nous considérons que ce chemin doit
continuer à être celui que nous
empruntons tout simplement pour bien
séparer un monde local du monde
parlementaire et en ne faisant pas
croire qu'il est nécessaire d'appartenir
aux 2 pourrait bien faire et bien faire
fonctionner ensemble
merci dans mon 22 monsieur benarroch
certains ça ne vous surprendra pas assez
c'est encore un amendement de
suppression de cet article bien entendu
puisque notre groupe est opposé à vous
le savez vous l'avez compris à la
pratique ancienne du cumul des mandats
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure pour nous
le cumul bloc le renouvellement de la
représentation témoin d'une conception
de la politique
et du politique dont l'objectif
principal est de concentrer le maximum
de pouvoir entre nombre restreint de
décideurs une au cumul permet par contre
d'accroître le nombre de personnes en
responsabilité de renforcer la vitalité
de la démocratie et la diversité de la
représentation politique et la confiance
des citoyens
les parlementaires ne nous semble pas
avoir besoin de cumuler des
responsabilités au sein des exécutifs
des collectivités pour s'engager
pleinement dans la vie politique locale
de leur circonscription chacun d'entre
nous en est l'exemple et pour conserver
une proximité avec le terrain et y mener
des actions cela fait partie intégrante
de nos missions et nous les menons à
bien quotidiennement par conséquent les
auteurs du groupe écologie solidarité
territoire du présent amendement de mode
la suppression de l'article 1er
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur oui madame la présidente
ça nous surprendra pas ceux que vous ne
surprendra pas je serais défavorable à
l'ensemble de ces trois 3 amendements de
suppression forcément puisque on vide de
son contenu cette ppl haut je voudrais
quand même rappeler que je pense que la
crise de défiance
entre le politique et nos concitoyens
n'est pas exclusivement lié certes au
cumul des mandats l'affaiblissement du
parlement
il ya plusieurs causes on pourra parler
on en parlera d'ailleurs
prochainement de des ordonnances et la
prolifération des ordonnances on peut
également parler du septennat au
quinquennat je peux être d'accord avec
vous mais force est de constater quand
même par expérience que quand un texte
arrive de l'assemblée nationale
je prends le texte climat et résilience
il y avait une disposition rappelez vous
un amendement déposé par un
parlementaire qui n'a jamais exercé de
mandat local et qui est imposée au flot
de véhicules des communes d'être 100%
propre à partir de 2025 pour s'aligner
avec le privé nous sommes tous opposés
parce que nous avons également une
expérience en tant que élu local et
surtout de l'ancienneté en tant que
maires ou présidents de département et
donc vous voyez l'utilité quand même
d'exercer à un moment donné une fonction
exécutif afin d'éviter ces écueils là en
matière législative c'est la raison pour
laquelle je serais défavorable aux trois
amendements merci la vie du gouvernement
madame la ministre
le gouvernement est favorable à ces
amendements puisque nous sommes en
cohérence avec la position que nous
avons sur le texte c'est-à-dire un avis
défavorable et la suppression de cet
article vise tout simplement faire
tomber l'article est donc à faire tomber
la proposition de loi
merci alors monsieur kerrouche
modification de brad we en réagissant
justo aux propos de monsieur le
rapporteur et en le faisant
respectueusement je pense qu'il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on dit aussi
il n'y a pas de prérequis en france qui
conditionne le fait que pour être
parlementaire il faut avoir été élu
local il faut faire attention parce que
mais je pense que ce n'était pas votre
attention ça voudrait dire que les élus
de la république en marche que comme
vous savez je n'ai pas l'habitude de
défendre je pense que tout le monde l'a
constaté et est ou serait illégitime
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas élus locaux
et je pense qu'il faut faire attention à
la façon dont ont formulé d'observation
on peut imaginer on peut imaginer aussi
que le fait d'avoir une expérience ne se
réduit pas dans la vie à une expérience
d'élu même si elle est importante le
fait d'être aux parlementaires c'est
aussi ce qu'on apporte en tant
qu'individu par son expérience
professionnelle par la trajectoire de
vie particulières que l'on a eu donc ces
élus sont légitimes pour autant on peut
imaginer que sur certains domaines il
est préférable d'avoir une expérience
locale encore une fois ce n'est même pas
en cause la légitimité qui est la leur
croire que celle ci est indispensable et
serait la seule façon pour que l'on
puisse fonctionner je pense que c'est
faux également on peut tout à fait être
au courant de ce qui se passe localement
sans être élu local et je le répète on a
beau avoir une histoire de cumul
extrêmement important en france il n'en
demeure pas moins que dans les
démocraties occidentales
cette anomalie n'existe pas ça n'empêche
pas les élus d'être connecté alors on
peut dire que nous somme exceptionnelle
en tous points mais on peut aussi
considérer que nous sommes atypiques sur
ce point en particulier
donc il nous semble inutile de revenir
sur cette loi
d'autant que et j'y reviendrai après
dès que cette porte est ouverte on voit
bien avec l'amendement qui suit le
sous-amendement de madame gars tels que
d'autres ports doivent s'ouvrir parce
que cette mesure spécifique ne suffit
pas même si alors même un président
guette elle
ne serait pas de surprise moi je suis en
profond désaccord avec nos collègues
parce que je pense que pendant le débat
où on a déplacé le débat sur la question
existentielle est très vrai de ce qu'est
devenu le parlement aujourd'hui pour
d'autres raisons
la proposition de loi qui est fait et
l'opposition à l'amendement de monsieur
qu'est rouge fait du fait qu'il ne
s'agit pas forcément de lire simplement
ce texte comme permettant un
parlementaire de cumuler un mandat local
il s'agit aussi de permettre un maire
d'une commune de 500 habitants de
devenir s'il le veut librement et
personne ne l'imposent à qui que ce soit
parlementaire il n'ya pas d'exigence à
ce qu'un parlementaire et un mandat
d'exécutif local je dis simplement que
moi je pense que la démocratie elle est
tellement forte et elle est tellement
vrai que les électeurs sont capables en
leur âme et conscience de savoir si leur
député maire
et efficace et 6 vols de ce candidat ou
d'un autre et que moi je m'attaque
personnes en île en illégitimité
s'il n'a pas de demanda bras et que
sincèrement je pense que très souvent
ici on reproche de ne pas faire
d'évaluation de l'efficacité d'une loi
chère collègue éric kerrouche cette loi
de 2014 qui est annoncé comme gazeuse n
a rien guéri parce que les
parlementaires ne sont pas contents les
élus locaux ne le sont pas on n'a pas
retrouvé la confiance des électeurs et
on met toujours autant d'abstention moi
je suis favorable à un nombre de mandats
limités dans le temps je pense que ça
c'est plus favorable à cette vision que
vous avez qui un enfermement dans une
doctrine qui était celle de 2014 et vous
n'avez rien de moderne en cela mon cher
collègue merci c'est le président lugo
j'ai un peu étonné parce que j'ai
entendu à plusieurs reprises que cette
proposition de loi relevait de certaines
anomalies mais être parlementaire est il
membre d'un conseil régional de plus de
trois millions d'habitants c'est pas une
anomalie et vous pouvez pas être maire
d'une commune de 50 habitants je pense
que vraiment il ya un vrai il ya un vrai
souci à ce niveau-là et puis aussi sur
le sujet il est pour moi difficile
d'accepter d'entendre qu'il suffit de
n'avoir qu'un mandat
pour avoir de la proximité
et bien si c'était vrai
on n'entendrait pas et je vois peut-être
pas mêmes élus que vous c'est
certainement pour ça on n'entendrait pas
de la part de certains élus nous dire
mais attendez mais qu'est-ce que vous
êtes allés voter qu'est-ce que vous êtes
allés voter sur ce sujet parce qu'on
bien dessus combien de votes on met
combien de lois on défend et qui
effectivement ne correspondent pas du
tout à la tante de nos concitoyens est
sûre sur le sur le problème de la
proximité sur la première à proximité
quand vous rencontrez un maire
qui vous explique un certain nombre de
choses vous pouvez comprendre ce qui
vous dit vous pouvez partager ce qui
vous dit mais il ya une chose que l'on
ne peut que l'on ne fait pas c'est qu'on
ne vit pas au quotidien ce cas les
difficultés qu un maire je pense que ce
serait bien effectivement qu'on y
réfléchisse
et qu'on regarde comment on peut faire
pour enlever cette anomalie qui vient
effectivement d'un cumul et comme l'a
dit un des orateurs tout à l'heure on
passe on passe de 104 360° à zéro degré
on est passé on pouvait être maire de
paris député président de la région ile
de france et aujourd'hui on ne pourrait
plus être
sénateur et maire d'une commune de 90
habitants 200 habitants je pense qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on y réfléchisse et le
bon sens paysan
[Musique]